E
DOING THAT WE ARE ABLE TO BRING
IT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU.
THE BIDEN AGENDA IS AS WE KNOW
FAILING ON EVERY FRONT OBVIOUSLY
END RATHER THAN ADMIT THEIR
SHORTCOMINGS, THE RESPONSE IS
ALWAYS THE SAME -- DOUBLE AND
TRIPLE DOWN ON MORE DESTRUCTIVE,
DELUSIONAL, DANGEROUS AND FAR
LEFT LUNACY -- FOR EXAMPLE WE
ARE NOW LEARNING MORE ABOUT A
NEW 1.5 BILLION -- WITH A B --
DOLLAR GRANT FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT TO
FUND WOKE PET PROJECTS
SURROUNDING SO-CALLED RACIAL
EQUITY AND ECONOMY KILLING
CLIMATE CHANGE INITIATIVES.
THE BEST PART, ALL OF THE FUNDS
ARE COMING FROM THE INPUT
STRUCTURE BILL THAT BIDEN SIGNED
LAST YEAR BUT JUST LIKE THEIR
COVERT RELIEF BILL WASN'T
ACTUALLY ABOUT COVID, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL COVERS WAY
MORE THAN TRADITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HERE WITH MORE GIVING US A BIT
MORE BACKGROUND AND ANALYSIS,
FORMER HUD SECRETARY ONE OF OUR
FAVORITES OF COURSE
DR. BEN CARSON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
WE KNOW THE NATION IS IN SOME
DEGREE OF TROUBLE PICKLE YOU ARE
AN EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF MAN
THAT THIS NATION PRODUCES AND
DELIVERS IT TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
YOU SERVE THIS COUNTRY, YOU
SERVE HER NOW WITH THE WORK THAT
YOU DO.
$1.5 BILLION, THE DIFFERENCE
THAT KIND OF MONEY COULD MAKE
AND THE QUALITY PEOPLE'S LIVES
AS THE ECONOMY CONTINUES TO
CRUMBLE WOULD BE ASTOUNDING,
WHAT DO YOU SAY WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS KIND OF SPENDING OF MONEY
ON ABSURD PROJECTS?
>> IT'S QUITE SAD THAT WE WOULD
USE THIS EXCUSE TO FUNNEL MONEY
IN FOR THE PET PROJECTS, THE
CHRISTMAS WISH LIST OF THE WOKE
LEFT.
SINGLING OUT RACIAL FAVORITES,
THAT DOESN'T REALLY DO ANYTHING.
IF YOU THINK BACK TO THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION, IT WAS A
PHILOSOPHY THAT A RISING TIDE
FLOATS ALL BOATS AND WE HAD THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
MINORITIES PARTICULARLY BLACKS
AND HISPANICS, WE HAD THE
HIGHEST WAGES.
WE HAD PRISON REFORM, WE CREATED
A SITUATION WITH HBCUs THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO COME CUP IN HAND
EVERY YEAR.
THERE WAS A WHOLE PLETHORA OF
THINGS THAT REALLY WORKED MUCH
BETTER THAN THIS EQUITY STUFF.
IF PEOPLE WOULD JUST STOP AND
EVALUATE THINGS ON THEIR FACE AS
OPPOSED TO LISTENING TO THE
PROPAGANDA, I THINK WE WOULD BE
MUCH BETTER OFF.
THESE GIFTS ARE USED TO FURTHER
DIVIDE THE AMERICAN POPULATION
IF YOU FAVOR ONE GROUP OR
ANOTHER ALL YOU ARE GOING TO DO
IS CREATE TENSION.
WE'VE GOTTEN TO THE POINT WHERE
WE THINK WE ARE ENEMIES, WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE -- WE HUNT
EACH OTHER'S ENEMIES, THE
ENEMIES ARE THOSE PURVEYORS OF
HATRED AND DIVISION WHO SEEMED
TO HAVE A TREMENDOUS MOUTHPIECE
AND FACILITATED BY THE MEDIA.
>> Tammy: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, IT'S A VERY
WISE ASSESSMENT BECAUSE LOOKING
AT THE NATURE OF WHAT THEY WOULD
PROPOSE, THINGS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION, WE
HAVE HEARD THEM ABOUT THE RACISM
OF HIGHWAYS AND HOW EVERY
DECISION EFFECTIVELY THAT IS
MADE IS THIS STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND THAT MONEY IS SOMEHOW GOING
TO CURE THAT.
WHAT MAKES EVERYBODY THINK IS,
THE SYSTEM YOU CAN'T WIN AT ALL,
YOU ARE LOST, EVEN THE ROADS ARE
AGAINST YOU.
DOESN'T THAT GO TOO FAR?
OR DO YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY BELIEVE IT
BUT THEY HAVE DISCOVERED WAYS TO
MANIPULATE AND IF THEY WERE
REALLY INTERESTED, THEY WOULD BE
DEALING WITH WHAT YOU WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT AT THE BORDER.
WE GOT ALL BECAUSE OF PEOPLE
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY
INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
DESTROY THIS COUNTRY, IT'S ONLY
THE GRACE OF GOD THAT IS SAVING
US, WE CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A
GOVERNMENT THAT SEEMS TO
UNDERSTAND THE DANGERS THAT ARE
PRESENTED BY DOING THINGS --
THAT'S TRULY THE REASON THAT
AMERICAN CORNERSTONE WAS CREATED
TO HELP FOCUS PEOPLE ON THE
THINGS THAT MAKE THIS INTO A
GREAT NATION, THINGS THAT ARE
BEING ATTACKED ON A DAILY BASIS,
OUR FAITH IN OUR FAMILIES -- WE
ARE GOING HAVE TO BE SMART
ENOU